JENNY BROWN: Today we're talking
about Domains, Databricks,
VMware Engine, and budgets.
I'm Jenny and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We're introducing Cloud
Domains in preview,
which simplifies domain
registration and management
within Google Cloud.
Cloud Domains improves the
custom domain experience
for developers,
increases security,
and supports
stronger integrations
around DNS and SSL.
It offers easy domain
renewal through Cloud Billing
and permissions via IM.
Check out the release
for more information.
By deploying on Google
Cloud, Databricks users
can build data lakes fast and
integrate data science and ML
workloads on their path
towards production.
Databricks capabilities in
data engineering and analytics
are complemented by Google
Cloud's global secure network.
And all together, customers
get an enterprise-ready cloud
service with a
Databricks experience
that's reliable, scalable,
secure, and governed.
Read more about this
integration on the blog.
Google Cloud VMware Engine
simplifies the challenges
of moving and modernizing
critical workloads
to the cloud.
To make networking simpler and
enhance security management,
we've recently released
improved networking,
support, scalability, and
support for the VMware
platform, and improved
reach, among other things.
Check out the blog
for the full list.
Budgets and alerts are
probably the first step
to staying on top of
your Google Cloud costs.
If you care about money,
you should definitely
set up a budget.
Check out the blog post Mark
Mirchandani to learn more.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.